(applaudissements)
- Un pas vers une ère
industrielle plus verte.
Le Canada et l'Allemagne signent
un accord sur l'exportationututr
l'énorme machine industrielle à
demande d'ici quelques années.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier - C'est un vote de confe
envers l'innovation canadienne
nos travailleurs. Et c'est
un vote de confiance en l'avenir
en matière d'énergie propre.
- L'objectif est d'exporter de
l'hydrogène à faible émission
et ses dérivés vers l'Allemagne
en place une chaîne
d'approvisionnement
transatlantique complet avant
2030. Rien, donc, pour aider
l'énergie russe à court terme.
nenenenenenenenenenenenenenenene
péninsule de l'ouest de l'île de
Terre-Neuve pour leur annonce.
Un endroit où doit voir le jour
une usine qui utiliserane pour e
de l'hydrogène vert.
Dans la première phase, jusqu'à
164 éoliennes devraient être
construites. Un prààààààààààààà.
Le Canada a beaucoup à faire
pour respecter ses objectifs.
JÉRÔME DUPRAS, prof. titulaire,
Chaire de - - - - - - - - - - Çs
pipelines pour le transporter.
Ça prend des terminaux
pour le mettre à la masse.
- Au-d
à bâtir, il y a aussi d'autres
incertitudes. Quelle sera la
demande pour l'hydrogène
canadien dans quelques années?
qu'on va investir dans nos
infrastructures pourraient êtr
rentable dans une... une optique
temporelle de 10, 15, 20 ans,
sera substitué par d'autres
technologies? Donc, c'esçaça,
ici, le pari qui est à prendre
pour l
pour le Canada.rorororororororoe
l'hydrogène estnene option
viable, au moment où plusieurs
pays cherchedededededededededed.
- L'invasion injustifiable de
la Russie de l'Ukraine à changer
la donne de façon profonde,
et acc
allait peut-être prendre encore
plusieurs années, pe--être
une décennie avant qu'on fasse
- Au-delà du rapprochement
avec l'Allemagne, cette entente
Neuve-et-Labrador, une province
productrice de pétrole qui
les énergies renouvelables
tout en créant de bons emplois
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Stephenville,
à Terre-Neu